oh
[ __ ]
i feel like i'm in a [ __ ] simulation
half of the time where everyone is like
actually [ __ ]
so recently andrew tate has been banned
from all social media platforms they did
it all within the course of 48 hours
every single platform just completely
decided to rip his you know his right to
free speech away do they put out any
type of public statement when they do
that or they just of course not they
don't have a real reason why to ban them
it's because it goes against their
agenda and they like making men weaker
so they just get rid of them same thing
if you go and look up alex jones on
youtube you can't even find any any
videos of him actually talking the first
things that come up are all of him in
court um even yesterday when i mentioned
alex jones to you that's not that's not
their accident because what they do is
when they they take away this guy's
platform they can say whatever they want
about him and everyone will believe it
just like how they said he's a
misogynist and a horrible person and he
beats a woman he's a sex trafficker all
the stuff that's taken out of context
and that's what he's getting cancelled
for even though none of it's actually
true but you're talking back to i'm
talking about the tape yeah it actually
makes me pretty sad because they're not
even hiding it anymore that they're just
censoring um well they haven't been
hiding it for quite a while now no but
this is like a real it seems like they
would actually they had actually uh
calmed down a little bit on the
censorship and now that we are coming up
we're with another election with another
election they're they're revving it back
up again and and this is the beginning
when people are going to finally start
paying attention in the next six to
eight weeks about the elections and
what's going on in the for the midterms
everybody's gotta
be fed their agenda full steam ahead no
yeah sneakers up next i don't see him
having a platform i know that in a year
once we're a lot bigger i don't see
myself having a platform i i just don't
it just makes me it makes me sad that
they're not even hiding that they're
literally sensing censoring people for
spreading what i like to say good all
right well get done being sad and let's
figure out how to get past it because
there's other platforms out there that
we can that we can bring people to
because free speech matters more than
anything and everybody should be on the
platforms where free speech is the is
the jam and let them all sit in their
echo chamber i don't care if somebody
says something i don't like i'll react
to it i'll feel about it i might get mad
i might get happy at whatever but yeah
that's their damn right in america
anyway i i mean all right well so
anyways tate made this final message and
he posted it on his website rumble and
getter uh i don't know i really haven't
watched much for this i've kind of tried
to save it for when we react to it
together i've seen some clips on tick
tock but it looks really good so i'm
excited to watch it all right i'm
already gonna say i'm i'm yeah i'm angry
about censorship but i do not believe
this will be his final message because
you
you can't keep a good guy down yeah
saying i i worship andrew tate all of
you out there because i get a lot of
that oh yeah mom wants tate no well
overall what would you give tate 1 to
10.
he was gonna get an eight he's down to
at least a seven i know it was six i
largely agree with what he says i don't
agree with all of his life and i've i've
been very clear on what i agree with and
don't but i think he's a decent guy and
he's he's not the devil they're
certainly friends the same thing they
did with trump the stuff that they
demonized him for is stuff that he
didn't even actually do yeah trump's not
perfect and he's done some bad stuff but
the stuff that they make him out to be
the bad guy for wasn't even true that
that's what i hate that's oh it wasn't
even true yes i know and now and once
it's been proven to be not true they
just act like they never said what they
said and they literally act like they're
not trying to make like it's so obvious
what their agenda is to literally make
men weaker they're literally portraying
like non-stop [ __ ] trans animals and
kids shows and giving kids hormones
they're literally trying to brainwash
the new generation of people and
becoming weaker and censoring this stuff
it's so obvious what they're trying to
do it is they're trying to forget sad
forget sadness a big reason that they
did that angry the feminist because this
is it's not okay let's keep going and
start it i was thinking for a long time
how to start this video
because it needs to be concise
and compendious
but i also want it to be very very
comprehensive
and i guess the best place to start is
at the beginning
uh there's been many different versions
of my life story which have been put on
the internet as of late and from many
years ago
but i'm going to give a very very quick
overview of my story
my life has always been difficult
i've certainly had a difficult life
i preach to the people who follow me
that as a man
trauma and difficulty is extremely
important because it's the building
blocks for
mental fortitude and physical fortitude
so i'm very very happy that my life has
been difficult because it's impossible
to become a capable man
or a man of my capability without
struggling with
facing serious adversities
without trying to overcome
often insurmountable odds
i grew up in
south side of chicago
i'm obviously a person of color i uh
no he's a white oppressive man actually
he is yeah he's a white oppressor
in south side yeah i grew up in south
side of chicago with the black father
you know he's a white oppressive man
misogynist in school to a degree
and my father always taught me to stick
up for myself i was never allowed to run
and cry to authority
i was told that if someone wants to mess
with you or come at you
you can't always go tell the teacher
sometimes you have to deal with it
i was actually picked on by these two
these two kids
well you you did the same thing with me
when i was little you didn't tell me to
go snitch and tell on teachers like if
someone was messing with me you guys
kind of encouraged giving them a quick
whack it just it sets you up for real
life problems better where you don't
always think to go to an authority
that's what they're doing like even with
little things like that it sets you up
for relying on something greater than
you like the government yeah like when
you're told from little every single
problem you need to go to your teacher
and [ __ ] about it once you get older
that same thing becomes you going to the
government or going to some higher power
and relying on something else and not
relying on yourself and dealing with
[ __ ] on your own just they make you weak
from the start right they keep and they
don't give you baby all this this
generation of kids that are now in
college are
from this
um excuse me generation of helicopter
parents who if two little kids got into
a scuffle over a toy in the playground
the parents came in and made them
apologize and had a whole conversation
about sharing and blah blah blah blah
blah blah you know we didn't do that
with you you know yes yes i was i'm
about manners and i was on your behalf
nice but you know we also let you let
you resolve within reason do you
remember i got in a fight with like
omari or that kid in like second grade
because he was like i don't even know if
i told you this but we're in like second
grade it's ringing about when we were in
second grade he's like i banged your mom
stop the cow
i punched him in the face he said that
yeah yeah we were like eight that's
hilarious and i punched him in the face
and i got in trouble but i don't even
think i told you that till now no i
would have remembered the i that the
mom part this little eight this little
eight-year-old
oh i'm proud of you keep going standing
up for my honor thanks i was riding the
school bus home
i think i was around five and they were
around seven they were a bit older than
me and they used to pick pick on me on
the school bus they'd sit behind me
throw things at me hit me etc
and i came home and i told my dad about
it i said dad these two kids are picking
on me every single time i get the school
bus i don't know what to do
and my dad said i'm not going to call
the teacher
because the teacher ain't on the bus and
i'm not going to call the school bus
driver because they're busy driving son
if you want to deal with this
you're going to have to deal with it
yourself
and i said but dad they're bigger than
me what do you want me to do there's two
of them and they're bigger than me
and at the time i just come home from
school and i was holding a lunch box my
dad pointed and said you have a lunchbox
son
teach
him so
weeks had passed it was a few weeks they
kept picking on me kept picking on me
and i felt myself sitting there getting
more insecure and the rage was boiling
inside of me and one day one of them
slapped me in the side of the face from
behind i was sitting on the chair he
slapped me in the face from behind
and instantly i don't know what it was
but this was the day i had enough and i
turned with my lunchbox and swung it
over the back of the school bus chair
and caught him and busted his eye clean
open the plastic batman lunch box hit
him in the eye and blood started
squirting everywhere
all the children started screaming
and as i did this the bus had just come
up to a stop it was a few stops before
my stop but it had stopped and as the
bus stopped and the screaming happened i
just got up and i ran and i just ran off
the bus and ran home i've never run so
fast
or so far in my life i was full of
adrenaline i just ran ran ran ran ran
when i got home
i had blood on my clothes my dad looked
at me so what happened i said
that kid i won't say his name i said his
name at the time i said that kid he hit
me in the face and i just i had enough
of him getting hit in the face
and i was still holding
the lunchbox but it was all smashed up
where i'd hit him with it
and my dad kind of smiled a little bit
and said don't worry son
get in the car we got in the car we went
to walmart we walked up and down the
aisle
and he looked and picked up another
lunch box an exact replica of the same
blue batman lunch box
gave it to me and said i'll buy you as
many of these as you need
and that was the last we spoke of it
funnily enough i never saw that kid
again i don't know if he changed schools
i don't know what his parents did but i
never saw that child again
so
even from a very very young age i was
taught that going to authority and
crying
and hoping someone else is going to fix
your problems
is not the way a man should conduct
himself
when i left literally all the things
that a man needs to become a successful
person who can raise a family they're
trying to strip that away from men now
all of us they're stripping it away from
all of us not just men it's crazy
chicago
i moved to luton england which was
multiple times voted the worst town in
england it's a high crime rate it's a
very bad area
my mother and father broke up so i was
in a single mother household
and now i'm a person of color in a
single mother household
i'm also the only american at the time
um in in lewton
and i had again repeat problems in
school i was picked on for being the
only american i was picked on for not
knowing things i should have known
because i hadn't been through the
english educational system i'd been to
the american educational system
and i had trouble in school again but i
stuck up for myself unfortunately
nothing got violent at any point when
people made fun of me i stood up and
said listen don't make fun of me
i'm from a different place and i talk
differently and i always understood
that
standing up for yourself i never went to
the teacher i never cried to anybody
else i just stood up for myself and over
time people learnt respect for me and my
boundaries
and they were very respectful of me
and i had a very positive experience
from then on out in school by simply
standing up for myself because this is
how i was taught to act in high school i
ended up having a reputation of a guy
that nobody really messed with i
certainly wasn't a bully absolutely the
opposite but no one really picked on me
i actually had a friend in school who
was gay
i had five main friends in school and i
was also friends with a gay guy
and
he would make fun of me
for being american
and i would make fun of him for being
gay back then but the world was a very
very different place this is many many
years ago and we like you can't even say
that nowadays without people coming
after you it's crazy like that's normal
that's normal for kids to to be like
that well kids kids are still like that
and the anybody that but they're like
that says that they're not is in
fantasyland kids find
it we'll just make fun of everybody for
everything
their defense mechanism it's niaphora i
say they say that uh i i was skinny i
was so skinny when i was little that
they tortured me all through elementary
school because i looked like i was
little they called skeletor it just
on and on and on skinny mini literally
all guys inside of their friend groups
like make racist and like and like bad
jokes to each other literally every guy
in their friend group so it's kind of
ridiculous to try to like cancel this
when literally everybody does it well
you know joking around joking around
with your friends
thinking about this maybe i zoned out
for a second was this this was they
weren't an actual argument no he was
with his friend
you did so now he was um he said i had a
gay friend in school he used to make fun
of me for being american i used to make
fun of him because he's good okay yeah
[ __ ] big deal that's what we do stop
[ __ ] crying about everything
everything doesn't have to be all roses
everything will never be unicorns
rainbows and sunshine ever you'll have
moments of that the rest of it is going
to be either think about in the middle
or [ __ ] get used to it that's it that's
life think about who's telling you to
get offended over this stuff it's not
your friends and people and normal
people around you it's the media and
people on top trying to tell you that
you need to get offended over to
everything it's to keep you distracted
to keep you divided distracted
distracted because they can control you
it all makes perfect sense once you back
up and really look into it why you think
the things you think who told you to
think like that start critically
thinking if you think they're the
politicians i don't care who you follow
do you think the politicians really deep
down care no
about you nobody cares about you except
for you your parents and your boys
that's it nobody else cares about you
and you know what nobody really cares
about you except yourself because you're
the only one that's going to be able to
make the success in your life that you
want to have yeah hopefully you care
about yourself but think about it you're
acting like government officials people
like teachers like they don't really
care about you they don't you you only
you and your family the people closest
around you actually care about each
other everything else comes with an
agenda and a motive nobody cares i would
say if you have a teacher who really
cares about you learning about how to
read and write and
you know science and math and the things
that will teach you how to think not
what to think those are the teachers
that care about you the ones that are
trying to really shove down your throat
political and social agendas they're
also brainwashed by the bigger system
dude and you gotta really you know you
gotta sit in the class and smile and
wave like the little penguins and just
get through it and get the hell out of
there it's you're not going to change
their opinions it's not you know you
just go out and live your life dude
especially the politicians and stuff but
do not buy into it those politicians and
people they literally see you as numbers
they they don't see you as even people
you they you they literally look at you
like like a number that's how they look
at you they don't give a [ __ ] about you
and if you want to prove that because if
you think it's just something that we're
saying don't listen to the news about
politics go read the policies that
they're discussing read them for
yourselves some of them are hard some of
them are really thick and written by old
crusty people who have intellects and
vocabularies that are far beyond the
average person but you know what oil up
your brain and get to it and then you'll
see the difference between fact and
opinion and fact and media hype and
sensation because they're just trying to
get a song emotional and they've done a
great job of it look at you know we're
just not just america we can see in the
whole world this is and throughout
history this is what's been done yeah
yeah let's keep going [ __ ] the man we
had friendly banter back and forth but
we were very good friends and i stuck up
for him and prevented anyone else
picking on him
all of the time
and the banter between us the locker
room talk
which would be considered absolutely
unacceptable today at the time was very
very normal and we had a great time we
were good friends and i heard from him
actually it's still normal it's just not
videos i've been put everywhere but it's
normal and the video i love it taken out
of context making it seem like you know
everybody
used to be
when i was 12 and 13 we were evil we
were we were genuinely evil making like
like horrible jokes but everyone does
that at that age it's normal it's
learning it's part of rebellion in a
weird way and it's also because they
tell you this stuff is so bad now from
such a young age that as a kid in your
like early teens you think that the [ __ ]
you're not supposed to say is even
funnier so by them constantly promoting
like not saying this this is bad it
ultimately makes these kids want to be
more [ __ ] up and say those jokes that
goes with everything so i've said it you
i'm sure you've heard me say this but
i've been saying for at least 20 years
when i was a kid and i'm not advocating
for young people drinking alcohol okay
but we did we were young we drank but it
was easy for us to get our hands on a
six pack of beer have that little
rebellious thing we did i think we were
such bad asses and go sit in the
schoolyard and drink a six-pack and they
then turned the country on its head and
made it so impossible for a kid to walk
into a store and get beer and the laws
became so stringent the 21 plus went
from eight you were 18 then it went to
21 and then they cracked down like crazy
on those laws making it a major crime
for a cust for a store to sell a
six-pack to a bunch of kids so kids that
natural inclination to rebel to to to do
that thing that is you know out of reach
right that that's so bad that's fine i
won't go to the corner store and buy a
six-pack i'll go to the corner drug
dealer and buy god knows what off of him
and be unsafe and be so far unsafe and
now look at what we have we have this
massive drug epidemic in our country and
it is largely in my opinion or at least
in large part because
you stop letting kids be you know have
that little that little taste of
rebellion with some beer or some vodka
let them have it and then they'll move
on and grow up better after this ban and
he said you should mention the fact that
the things they say about you completely
aren't true
and this leads me on to the reason i
believe these narratives have managed to
gain such a foothold in popular
consciousness
due to the fact i've managed to develop
an iron mind
because i'm probably the only individual
on earth who can be vilified to this
level without taking personal insult and
without being emotionally affected
what i have done is i've allowed certain
narratives to gain traction which i
shouldn't have allowed to gain traction
because they didn't personally bother me
because i know they are false
i live with a very very pure heart
i'm a religious man
i go to church and who follows me
in detail knows i donate huge sums of
money to the church
and as long as i knew the truth of my
heart and god knew the truth of my heart
i wasn't interested in lies being
purported
i now understand that's wrong because
even though i've done nothing wrong
even though it doesn't emotionally
affect me even though god and myself
know what my innocence
the public consciousness has been
polluted to a point where narratives are
being purported which are absolutely and
utterly false
and it's having a genuine negative
impact on the people who i care about
and the people who care about me
and despite the fact it doesn't
emotionally affect me as a man i have a
duty to protect all of those i love and
for this reason these narratives start
to become very very harmful
i was on the understanding that on the
internet people don't like you
it doesn't matter who you are it doesn't
matter what you say there's going to be
some people who don't like you and the
people who don't like you are not
interested in the truth
what they are interested in is finding
some lie that they can latch onto
and accelerating that lie
on as much as possible via their
platforms to try and paint a negative
picture
they literally they've done this in so
many ways to him even still calling him
like a sex trafficker and an exploiter
for running a webcam business that is so
insane that there's people who genuinely
think he's a sex trafficker because he
ran like an essentially an only fan's
management service like the stuff he's
getting canceled for is so stupid it
genuinely hurts my head it's like what
can we say online without getting
canceled and taken out of contact i mean
he didn't care about getting not getting
cancelled and look at him now we i i
don't care about getting canceled but
like there's people so much greater
above us it's like what can you even do
well i don't know about us but i do know
that this man is going to be okay
because here's what happens sometimes
when they cancel people they give them
they end up giving them an even bigger
platform because for all the people out
there that never heard of andrew tate
now he's news yeah he's on the actual
news so all the old people are starting
to know of him and who knows hopefully
he makes his own platform where he can
go and have like actual freedom of
speech and then a lot of people go there
and ultimately just boost him yeah even
bigger and he's still all over tick-tock
but i'm assuming they're going to
implement some software that can detect
his voice and face and and ban those
videos that'll probably come pretty soon
did twitter get rid of him too
he's been gone from twitter for a while
i hope elon buys twitter i hope it works
out
a lot of these
attacks against me are disguised
under the virtue of caring about women
but none of these people who are
attacking me care about women none of
them donate to women's cherries none of
them donate to charity like i do none of
them help anybody like i do i'm about to
show later on in this video proof of the
massive work i do for helping people
they don't help anybody
all they do is just attack me
and use fake virtue the fact they
pretend to care as a reason to attack
somebody who they personally don't like
and it's very very different to actually
care about an issue or weaponize an
issue and pretend to care to try and
damage someone else's life so crazy how
ironic it is that so many of the other
people trying to cancel him are
literally like actually bad people to
woman in person and they don't do
anything to actually help them meanwhile
he literally does donate to charity we
talk about this all the time
these are very very different
things and this is the reason why i have
not tried
to dispel these myths as hard as i could
have because i understood that these
people are always going to hate me and
they're always going to lie about me no
matter what i say or do
but considering in light of the final
ban
and considering i have the public
consciousness i think it's extremely
important that for myself and for my
family for people i care about
that i tell the truth and i make the
truth known to the world because that is
the only intention in my video is to sit
and tell the truth and the fact that i'm
a very very iron-minded individual who
is not negatively affected by these
smear campaigns
is not reason enough for me not to sit
take time and dispel all the negative
things which are said about me
i am fully aware
that not everybody is going to agree
with what i say
i don't think there's a person on the
planet you can find
who has a 100 approval rate there's
always going to be somebody who
disagrees with what you say
if i said the earth was round there
would be a contingent of individuals on
the planet who disagree with me
i have no problem with people
disagreeing with me
i have no problem with being seen as
controversial for some of the things
i've said
however
i do have two significant problems i
would like to address
the first is i do not like absolute and
utter lies being told about me
i do not like having
long-form video of me
cut up
elements taken out of context the
tonality of the joke removed and
purporting an image of me that's not
true that's something i do not like
i do not like false accusations of
criminal activity
like i said literally the same thing
they did with trump and i'm not even
that big of a trump supporter but i at
least acknowledge that 90 of the stuff
that they're going after him for was
taken out of context just to demonize
him they're doing the same thing they
can do whatever they want and then when
they take away your platform they can
literally say whatever they want because
you can't defend yourself alex jones too
the reason so many people hate him is
for the sandy hook thing and they don't
even really know what he fully said
about it i truly don't i have only seen
the anti-alex headlines but i'll tell
you i'll give you a great trump example
there was this uh
all the liberal media outlets were were
showing this clip of donald trump
shaking hands with this whole line of
people that were there to meet him and
there was a little kid in a wheelchair
and and he passed over the little kid in
the wheelchair and they're like donald
trump doesn't even bother with disabled
people but when he walked in the room
what they they edited the video so that
they left out when he walked in the room
the very first person he walked over to
was the little kid and he shook the
kid's hand and they talked for a minute
and then he went and shook everybody
else's hand so he treated that kid like
the most important person in the room
and they twisted it and that's a perfect
perfect example of how they do that to
opponents in order to gain power what
i'm struggling with is you know that was
a political race for the most important
political seat on earth
this man is he really this dangerous
that's what is i'm having a hard time
wrapping my head up because
this is nice dangerous and this powerful
in the minds of the general populace
that he should be eliminated worldwide
from social media it's unbelievable yeah
but he is though it literally goes
against everything that they want
getting out it is that dangerous to them
to those to those platforms wow it's
insane to comprehend basically talks
about things think about for yourself
he's not even political just think about
what the people in control are trying to
show you it's pretty easiest to see to
tell what they're showing you yeah like
non-stop non-stop black lives matter
propaganda you know making men weaker
constant [ __ ] you can be whatever
gender you want constant [ __ ] those
people at the top are the ones that in
control and the ones showing you all
this stuff so then obviously when
someone here is coming in with logic
teaching men to be men self-improvement
they don't want that that's not what
they want they want you weak addicted to
porn lazy
no no free spirit they want that
destroyed they want that beaten out of
you but the reality is they can't beat
it out of us and i've said this to you
before i know it's easy to get really
angry and and scared because it is a
little scary but outside of the media
regular all the regular people out here
they're they're they're men they're
women they're raising their children to
be men and women and if the kid comes
you know when it's 25 says i want to
change genders i want to wear a dress i
want to wear whatever go ahead have at
it but we're all out here raising our
kids with our own values that's another
thing that i really do not like
i am totally aware
that not everybody is going to like me
i have no problems with that i think
anyone who decides to get big on the
internet needs to be very very prepared
for a contingent of people to not be
happy with what they say
i could make a youtube channel dedicated
to the fact that i believe the world is
round and there would be a large
or semi-large proportion of people who
would disagree with me i don't think
there's a single creator online that has
a 100 approval rate
i have a lot of people who love what i
say i have a lot of fans a lot of people
are dedicated to my channel and i have a
lot of positivity online and i have a
small contingent of people who are very
very offended by what i say
we often talk about in the modern world
the inclusivity of different cultures
different ways of life different
sexual orientations and how we need to
be tolerant and understanding of all
these different people's life paths and
by extension
there are different ways of viewing the
world
i'm a unique individual as is everybody
else and i have a unique life path that
has led me to unique points of view
i think that all of the people who
disagree with me are very very welcome
to disagree with me because they have
had a unique life path and a different
point of view and i respect that
absolutely
i would never
shout for any of the people who disagree
with anything i say to be silenced or
canceled right i don't think that that
helps the world i think that discourse
is always going to be the way that we
lead ourselves to the truth and if
anybody has anything
contrary to say about any of my points
of view i welcome it i like to hear it
and as long as it's in a respectful and
adult manner i often platform it on my
platforms as much as possible so i can
sit and discuss
and i can learn things
because if i have a point of view when
someone challenges it in a very adult
correct logical way very often i have
changed my point of view
and this is really really really good
for me as a person to grow and for the
audience to grow and i know i've changed
many other people's minds when they've
come to debate with me and this is the
beauty of being human
so i have no problem with being disliked
i do have a problem with a few things i
have a problem with
long format things i've said
being taken out of context
taking a small clip from a two-hour
piece of video then with careful editing
removing of tonality and changing my
intention behind the words painting me
to be a criminal or a bad person when i
am not
i do have a problem with false criminal
accusations when i do not have a
criminal record and i have never had a
criminal record in any country on the
planet i do have a problem with this and
also i have a problem with the fact that
social media has changed so much in
modern times
a lot of the things i said would that
are being used against me were said five
or six years ago in long format video
and as of late with tick-tock with
youtube shorts with instagram reels it's
very very easy to take two hours of
video
snip out 10 seconds
edit it up quickly on a phone app
and then blow it up to millions and
millions of views with all context
removed all tonality removed and makes
it look like i'm saying things i did not
say or i mean things i did not mean
and this is something that i can't
control
i became the most googled man on the
planet and to a degree i'm a victim of
my own success because now people are
trying to find
any little clip of anything i've ever
said remove all the tonality and just
blow it up to try and get views to be as
controversial as possible how crazy is
that that stuff that you said when you
weren't even famous years ago can come
back and literally ruin your life so
like right now we're not we're not
really famous so we're just saying
whatever we want let's say in a year
from now i'm one of like the most famous
people around and then they can just go
back to these videos of me right now as
a regular eight like 19 year old kid and
just ruined my life it's kind of a crazy
thought and it's pretty like pretty wild
to think about yeah it got really scary
for a while when it first started
happening but now i can tell you that i
don't know good solid half of america
that i know as soon as that happens
they're like come here kid i'll give you
a job what do you need let me help you
because everyone's over it i don't want
to be you've got people being judged for
something they said in the uh in the
third grade you know like the kid you
mentioned before yeah i know i banged
your mother like does he need like an
obnoxious little thing that he said as a
nine-year-old held against him like he's
he he's he's a woman hater now for the
rest of his life i mean but that's what
they're trying to do and it's gotten to
the point where everyone is just like
shut up already so i know that i've i
i've been paying attention to that
longer than you have you got to be
ashamed of yourself [ __ ]
real talk you got to be ashamed of
yourself old as you is so you're still
in the in the earlier stages where it
can just be like mind-blowing and but
i'm telling you nobody cares anymore go
ahead cancel us cancel me cancel tate
you think it's going to hurt him thank
you now he's on the map for a whole
bunch of other people his life isn't
going to change at all he's literally
helping people he's literally helping
people telling them like stop being
depressed go go become a better person
teaching men like their like true values
keep canceling us keep canceling us
don't worry
once you've then canceled everybody
because everybody nobody is without sin
or transgression or a weak moment nobody
so then we're all cancelled we're on the
same boat great we're back where we
started go to hell
[ __ ] off i understand why they're doing
that they're doing that because they
want the views for themselves but
they're not taking into consideration
how that affects me and my personal
image as a whole
and i think
the things i've just highlighted has now
culminated in the media believing
something about me which is so
pertinently false
based on videos i have never even made
purported and accelerated and
advertised by people who i don't even
know
with such a small piece of video from me
with all context removed that i've now
become the number one villain of earth
and i truly believe that's unjust
and i want to discuss that here and
prove to the world in my final message
that i am not any of the things i've
been accused of
regardless of whether i am banned
reinstated remain on social media is
completely beside the point this is just
a matter of clearing the air while i
have the national consciousness i was
massively a victim of my own success
i decided
to accelerate my public persona and
presence
about six months ago
and i was massively successful
i became the most googled man on the
planet i am by the metrics
of the internet the most famous
individual who is currently alive in the
world today
that comes with a bunch of advantages
and disadvantages
we can go into those at depth
uh the disadvantages are safety aspects
safety concerns which we're going to
talk to about a bit later
i've had serious threats on my life i
receive over 5 000 death threats per day
so do people who i love and people i
care about they also receive death
threats the social media companies have
yet to take any action against this they
were uninterested in trying to police
this in any form
the advantages are of course is that i
have a massive effect on people
and i have had thousands of emails from
men saying you've saved me from
depression you've saved me from suicide
you helped me so much
the number one video on my youtube
channel my pinned video has been for
over a year
mind hacks how to beat depression how to
feel better as a man
sitting there believing that depression
is some monster from the sky that
strikes your brain and now you have no
control over and you must take pills
every day is the absolute enemy
to a g mindset i don't give a [ __ ] how
depressing my situation the only person
who can change it is me the only person
who can change how i feel about my
situation or try and affect the
situation directly is me even if you put
me in a situation i can't change if you
put me in jail and i'm depressed because
i'm in jail i still refuse to succumb to
depression i refuse to collapse mentally
and give up i know the only person who
can control my mind is me nobody's
coming to save me
as a man who's been through such a
difficult life i think i have a very
intimate understanding of difficulty and
how to grow as a man
like that is such a good message to be
spreading at least so much healthier
than if you feel sad what you need to do
is lay in bed all day eat junk food and
take pills i don't want to get too deep
into this again because we did that one
video on it and everybody and their
grandmother was uh
you can't even deny that that's such a
better message of course it is it
well i agree with him one thousand
percent in the case of circumstantial
depression there are times when there is
clinical depression that you can have
the best circumstances in the world and
your mind is not working properly and
that's where those pills come in as
either a temporary or permanent fix you
roll in your eyes at me but i agree with
him no matter what your circumstances
your attitude is your own and you can
change it i personally just believe that
you can take control of your mind even
more and um well i'd rather you be right
because if but i'm just going based on
my experience and my own research on it
having you know having depression be a
part of my life in many ways i'm not
gonna take away your platform to speak
your mind to become the kind of man that
can handle a difficult life because this
has been my life path this is what god
chose for me and this is what i've been
teaching and
i have affected positively
millions of people and i'm immensely
proud of that i truly am however people
couldn't stop talking about me and when
people were talking about me they
weren't doing it out of love for me
they weren't doing it because they cared
about me
the main reason people were talking
about me so extensively is because they
cared about their own channels
their own views they wanted their own
clicks
and they understood that if they can
make a youtube video purporting a lie
about me or saying bad things about me
it's more likely to get clicked it's
more likely to get watched controversy
and anger sells that's why even h3h3
continuously calling this due to sex
trafficker and woman beater i mean he
must know what this does
has anyone so i've heard these
accusations but i haven't i haven't
taken the time to really dig into it in
full disclosure has anybody put forth
any proof of any of these things no
there is no proof okay there's a video
of him like hitting a woman but it um it
was during like it was during what's it
called you know sexy time oh
you'll see it comes up i think
expose andrew tate is this
expose androtate is that
and what's happened is people through
their own selfish desires of trying to
piggyback off the back of my massive
fame and becoming the most famous man on
the planet have decided that making a
bunch of negative videos is a fantastic
way for them to personally gain clout
and personally gain views and clicks
which is what the internet is about and
we ended up in a situation where
videos of me from long ago
are being taken out of context
purposefully to try and report a
narrative which is not true because
people understand that's a very easy way
for them to gain some clout and leech
off of my success
that's all fine like i said i have no
problem with people disagreeing with me
being disliked etc however
when it has an effect to this magnitude
where i am genuinely seen as a negative
bad influence on the world when all of
the emails i receive from people who
watch me are positive saying that i'm
helping people how i've helped their
mind notice how it's only the people
that don't actually watch tate who don't
like him like um oh yeah yeah that goes
with everything if you ask like like a
random girl like what you think of tate
the sexist obviously i don't like him
have you watched him no i've seen the
note i've seen the instagram stories and
what he said he said you cho you you
gotta hit a woman like i said oh
that bill is racist that they're gonna
put through did you know that oh i
didn't read it i know i feel like i'm in
a [ __ ] simulation half of the time
where everyone is like actually [ __ ]
it's it's like genuinely how i feel half
of the time nowadays even like tick tock
comments anything i'm like how are these
people real what's going on i don't even
get it
keep going russian
it's really strange to experience such a
disconnect
to have
98 of the people who email you say how
fantastic you are and how much you
helped them
and then two percent of unknowns
threatening your life
and then everyone i meet on the street
saying such amazing things since i
become the most famous man on the planet
i have never once had a negative
experience in real life everybody who
meets me is very respectful a fan we
take pictures we shake hands nobody has
screamed at me in public nobody's come
up to me and called me names in public
nobody said i'm wrong i've been to over
2 that's going to be you and you're
coming out of your bugatti mom mom mom
20 countries i've never had a single
negative in-person experience ever
so the people love me
at the same time the media is saying i'm
hated it's a very strange disconnect
that i've been experiencing
and a lot of that has been purported and
accelerated by the fact that people are
trying to gain views on their own
channels separate to me nothing to do
with me
by accelerating lies
it's also
an interesting case study into internet
mass hysteria right if 50 videos come
out saying tate's a bad guy it takes a
lot of bravery for someone to come out
and say kate's not a bad guy despite the
evidence i can show evidence to the
contrary of this negative narrative
that's us yeah it is turning out to be
us huh team tate
but if somebody can see if a youtube
creator or content creator can see if
you make a negative video about tate you
get a bunch of clicks and everyone else
did it well then i may as well do it
that's where i'm smart i made the
thumbnail something like that and then
it's actually just us talking and saying
our thoughts inside okay they don't sit
there and go what about andrew what
about the truth of this what about the
effect on his life what about the effect
on his experience of of the world that
doesn't come into consideration what
comes into consideration is
everyone else did this and got a bunch
of views i want a bunch of views and
even though what they're saying is false
even though some of them know it's false
some of them may not but the ones who
are well researched know it's a lie it's
very very tempting for them to sit there
and do it anyway because there's no
repercussion there's no downside to them
all that's going to happen is they're
going to get a bunch of clicks a bunch
of views a bunch of comments a lot of
people defending me because they know
it's not true a lot of people are
agreeing with them who are less
researched they're going to completely
benefit and the only person who's going
to suffer is me and because i have an
iron mind and i wasn't emotionally
affected by this and i understood the
nature of the internet i didn't try to
combat it too hard i didn't know exactly
what i should do because i had already
told the truth on repeat many many many
times there literally is nothing you can
do because those people it doesn't
matter what you say don't believe it
they'll believe their own things
regardless you could literally prove
them wrong a million times and they
wouldn't care
but nobody would acknowledge it they
would just ignore it because it got more
clicks to purport the lies
so i thought
that's the nature of the internet i've
never been this famous before i guess
that's just how it goes unfortunately
now public consciousness via the media
has
genuinely bought into a construct where
people believe i'm somehow dangerous
when all i have done is save people from
depression
we talk about pretty crazy men's mental
health
we patty pimplet just fought and talk
about if you if you have trouble with
men's mental health come forward as i
said women talk to each other they
there's no stigma on women they sit
around and have a cup of tea and have a
jungle
true that men men don't lad men feel
like oh i can't go and say that to him
because you'll think i'm a little little
mushroom what i mean that's what men
think but
as i said in the cage i'd
much rather my friend come to me and
speak to me and cry on my shoulder than
me have to cry when i'm carrying his
coffin a week later i just wanted to
show the world that
if mental health could bring somebody as
big as me and as strong as me and you
know the stereotype everywhere jamming
of the world
to me knees then it could bring anybody
to the knees tyson fury talk about it i
talk about it
everyone tries to talk about it and
everyone says men
you should talk more talk to us
i try and encourage men to be strong i
say listen if you're depressed you need
to get in the gym a strong body is a
strong mind i sit there and by using my
lifestyle which is an aspirational
lifestyle that most men would love to
have purely because of the finance to
cars to freedom etc i encourage people
to work hard and try their best to
become the best version of themselves
and men are encouraged to talk and open
up but when i talk and open up and get
massive influence and start helping
people they're going to silence me
i've been nothing but a net positive for
the world that's truly how i view myself
and that's absolutely not really the
truth
however
i am very understanding of a changing
social media landscape and i'm also very
very understanding of my fame changing
and by extension i have some
responsibility to bear
i am a man who believes that he is
responsible for everything i think as a
man you should take complete
responsibility for your entire reality
it doesn't matter if i'm struck by
lightning
that is my fault
that's who i am as an individual and
it's been one of my keys to success to
never blame luck i love this personal
responsibility and the softies will say
if you try to purport personal
responsibility that it's victim blaming
and you know a woman getting
hammered and going you're you're blind
drunk dressed like a host
and then she she gets sexually assaulted
and she has zero responsibility for that
is it or even if she sleeps with the guy
willingly and then the next day regrets
it and then starts saying because that's
what it is a lot of the time too because
they do it consciously they're drunk so
i mean obviously as a guy you just
shouldn't do that out of like stay awake
stay awake
if you're in a relationship for multiple
years with a girl and you guys go out
drunk together and play around that's
fine but don't sleep with somebody new
drunk because you have
nowadays you've got a chance that that
girl regretting it and then saying you
assaulted her but that's not what i'm
talking about so a woman goes out she's
dressed like a hoe she gets smashed she
goes to you know god forbid gets goes to
a you know a party smashed meeting drunk
gets sexually assaulted and then she
says it wasn't her fault at all no you
have to have some street smarts you have
to be smart in the world you live in and
you're not going to a goddamn disney
party with prince everybody there is
prince charming so use your [ __ ] take
some personal responsibility i'm not
saying that that guy who sexual or guys
who sexually assaulted you are are right
everybody's wrong here but you put
yourself in a dumb bad situation and
everybody's going to go oh that sounds
like somebody who's never had it who's
your [ __ ] brain no they're going to
accuse me like i've never seen anything
or i've never been anything you don't
know [ __ ] about me i can be through
anything and still have my opinion so i
i hate when people do that too use your
brain have some common sense what he's
saying here is even if he got struck by
lightning his fault because he was
standing there you know and it's have
been in water about personal
responsibility how every choice we make
will have an outcome and sometimes even
good choices will have bad outcomes
because that's life but we don't need to
make but we have to take responsibility
for ourselves period it's the biggest
thing that's that yeah
and that and that has become that has
also gone out the window with logic
logic has gone because we don't want
people now to sit around and act like
life is just happening to me and i have
no control over anything that's [ __ ]
you don't if you're weakling you're
right you don't have control over
anything you just sit there and people
people people underestimate the power of
energy and what your mind can truly do
like they don't even comprehend that you
can like genuinely do whatever you want
no no this even 99 of the people seeing
me say this right now will will not
comprehend it but once you actually do
understand it it it's like a [ __ ]
gate like opens up and it's like a whole
new world where you're like holy [ __ ]
like i don't need to work that job i can
like actually do whatever i want to have
choices i have freedom freedom over how
i feel about things freedom over
how i grow my life who i hang out with
and so on anybody else to only blame my
self so despite everything i've just
said i still blame myself
and because my rise has been so meteoric
because i've become so famous so quickly
and because i've been producing content
for so long
even though i take absolute
responsibility
i'm in a difficult scenario where
videos that were made five or six years
ago in long form are now being cut into
five seconds accelerated and purported
now in line with my new line fame i
can't stop that happening
but i also understand i have a degree of
responsibility right because i'm the
most influential person on the planet
so
my responsibility is to make sure that
any kind of negative connotations in my
messaging are removed i want to stick to
my message
i don't want to backtrack i still want
to champion men's issues i still want to
champion physical and mental strength i
still want to champion the protection of
women i still want to do that however i
must be ultra aware of how i do that
because it would be unprofessional of me
as a man to sit and say that my
messaging does not have to change in
line with my fame
the way you can say things in a video
that gets 500 views is very different
than the way you can say things in a
video that gets 500 million views or 50
million views you have to change your
messaging the more people you reach
the more important it is that people do
not take your things out of context
right if not 0.1 percent of people
misunderstand you on a 500 person video
that will not have a large effect on the
world but if not 0.1 percent of people
misunderstand you on a video that has 50
million views
now you start to affect the world in a
negative way so i have to be very very
very careful in line with my new clown
fame and it's difficult because in the
world i'm in
if i sit down and do a three-hour
podcast
it's my job to be entertaining
and i want to give exciting answers and
interesting insights i think the reason
people follow me is because i have a
very firm understanding of the english
language a very good grasp
of the way to construct sentences how to
be motivating how to be compelling
and i do that on purpose
but it's also very difficult for me
regardless of my intellect to now sit at
a podcast be interesting be exciting
give a compendiuous
and concise answer at the same time be
wary that in my one minute answer at any
point six seconds worth of it can be
taken snipped used against me and
weaponized
i don't know if my mind can handle all
those tasks at once it's not very often
i'm stumped but uh that is becoming
extremely difficult and i'm sitting here
thinking i've been offered that massive
podcast i don't even know if mr emery
tate could do that yeah
requests by the biggest podcast in the
world and i'm thinking how can i answer
questions how can i be a responsible
adult because that's what i am how can i
be a professional take responsibility
for my level of fame to make sure that
nothing can be taken out of context but
still tell my truth and still answer the
questions but construct my sentences in
a way where they can't be misrepresented
at all
and it's hard
because i think any content creator who
was suffering from what i've suffered
from if any content creator got as large
as i was and there was as many people
cutting up their videos as they were
mine and those people had a negative
agenda we could make mickey mouse look
evil you could make anyone look bad
i'm not saying i haven't given them ammo
of course there's been the odd clip that
made it easy for them i'm saying if
their intentions were to be as
provocative and negative as possible
when you're literally filming thousands
of hours of content
yeah there's going to be some clips that
are very easy to take out of context
absolutely i mean i'm sure that even
when i'm famous one day because i will
be famous since this is like my full
goal and that's what i'm putting my mind
to that they're going to come back to
videos like this and i'm going to have
to deal with [ __ ] from the og mom
reacts yeah
when we die they're going to pay off
play our evil clips and dance on our
graves
whatever whatever at least i'll have my
[ __ ] in my cars my land and my dogs
and that's why now i need to take a
break from all the podcasts i've been
invited on especially since i've been
banned i've been invited on the largest
platforms in the world i've had hundred
thousand emails of support
all the media channels want to talk to
me and i'm damn this really does make it
a lot more difficult to get him on the
pod now i had a plan in place to do it
but now and now we're just going to
adjust the plan that's it don't worry
about it this is exactly what you talk
about right yep no don't complain the
government this one's stopping you that
one's stopping you i'm not complaining
i'm just saying i had it i had a plan
that was pretty solid and now it's right
right right
imply you're complaining but yes no now
we just go all right how do we get
around over through that find a new plan
forge a new path that's it he's got to
go on joe rogan i mean that'll be so
[ __ ] cold he's probably recording
that as we speak yeah
i need
to make sure i'm not misunderstood
and i have to really be careful about
how i do that while not backing down on
my messaging
while still championing the things i
champion still believing in myself but
making sure i'm not misunderstood
and although i think on the internet i
am one of the most respected what are
the sleeping great feelings like i'm
getting more tired the more i drink it i
now need to once again improve myself
and improve my skills
and prevent
anybody being able to take me out of
context i might have to form a new way
for sentences to be constructed but if
that's what it takes that's what i
intend to do because with great
influence comes absolutely not really a
great responsibility and i do understand
that and i will blame myself
for the fact that people have managed to
do this to me regardless of the fact
that i did not want it to happen so let
me give a quick example of this
uh before i continue i want to say that
i often he just does [ __ ] and complain
to the absolute beauty of women i have a
very healthy relationship with my mother
i have women around me who truly are not
really love me
look at the baby and your little pumpkin
and that's tristan yeah okay
and that's their sister i guess you know
it's cute too relationships with females
i have no criminal charges for crimes
against females
nobody has come forward and accused me
of sexual misconduct
please understand we'll go into the the
romanian
house raid shortly but most people in my
position of fame have had women come
forward and say he raped me i'm the most
famous man on the planet there's not a
single female whose face you can name or
whose face you can picture that's come
forward and said i've raped her that's
pretty wild actually that i didn't even
think about about that until he just
said that holy [ __ ] like he literally
everyone else that gets famous gets some
kind of crazy uh yeah
yeah wow that we know that's wild yeah
not a single female has come forward
saying i've hurt her
not one there's a video from 10 years
ago that showed me
in a sexual act with one of my
ex-girlfriends
[ __ ] i didn't say the word list did i
say listen
hello everyone um i just wanted to say
something about the video that's been
released recently about me and my
ex-boyfriend and yo how does he pull
these girls oh my god every single girl
he's talked to is a 10.
it's just what we used to do it was just
pure game he's a great guy he would
never hurt anyone why would they record
that though that's so like he's fighting
the left understand the king shaming is
a negative thing from my understanding
she has come forward and said that it
was all just a game and still that video
is being used and sent around the
internet sam woman beater if i said it
was a game and she said it was a game
who are other people to then comment on
our lives it's so cool that even his
ex-girlfriends they're still like you
know they have a good relationship and
she can still
back him up and stuff yeah all right g
my [ __ ] i'm saying let's keep going
it's not a game it was between two
consenting adults and we decided to do
something ourselves and we both agreed
it was fine and she has not come forward
trying to accuse me of anything so who
are others to do that
that's just king see this is the this is
what frustrates me that he shouldn't
even have to respond to this this is his
personal life like private moments
between him and a girlfriend it's gross
same thing happened to dave fortnite i'm
not gonna lie i think that shit's weird
but um i'm not gonna i'm not gonna hate
yeah but if it's just because it's not
your yeah it's not your jam doesn't mean
that it's not theirs like let them have
no yeah if it's consensual there's
there's there's no issue with it men get
into rings and can consensually punch
each other in the face if you freaking
know when you're doing a little stinky
time what are you going to do you know
what i'm saying yeah keep going that's
all it is
so no women are accusing me of anything
no women accuse me of misconduct
i champion women all the time i say
about how they should be protected how
beautiful they are how much i love my
grandmother because of the amount of
children she had my grandmother had
nine children because it was my father
and and eight more they all had a bunch
of kids blah blah blah i stood there and
looked at my 93 year old grandmother and
there was a room a whole room full of
maybe 70 people that came from that one
woman
isn't that remarkable that nobody cared
about her career nobody asked what job
she did nobody asked how many times she
went to the club nobody asked if she had
time to go to festivals no you had 70
sentient beings including myself full of
life from one woman who dedicated
herself to being a mother and and a good
and a good wife how weird is it that
even saying that now is a is a bad thing
to say i know because it's it's better
off for a woman to be like independent
and go and start their own career like
why is that that's where the feminists
are [ __ ] hypocrites they only think
that if you go because
as a career woman then you're worthwhile
but if you want to be a homemaker and
raise your family and be a good support
to your husband that you're less of a
woman and it's such poor [ __ ] you could
i you know you can do either i don't
even understand the real idea is you
should be able to do whatever you want a
woman that's a homemaker isn't
necessarily forced into that position by
the patriarchy so thank god there are
women that want to take care of their
kids themselves and as a woman don't you
just naturally want to take care of your
kid like wouldn't you rather be there
the one raising your child instead of
being at an office all day like why is
this even a question i think that's a
beautiful thing raising your kids and
having a wife that wants to do that why
are we getting demonized for saying that
this is the norm it's so dumb they've
[ __ ] twisted everything the world is
literally upside down nowadays i don't
even like what what can you even say or
think anymore without being [ __ ]
criticized it's so stupid people have
lost their goddamn minds because of the
media and the people on top they want
society to crumble oh
[ __ ] i talk about how women are unique
and special and they can do things that
i'm sorry mom men can't do and still
these clips are taken out of context
let me give you an example i absolutely
not really love women i have nothing
against women i believe women are the
most precious things on the planet they
create life they should be protected
they should be provided for i would
never let a woman pay for a bill i would
never let a woman if someone touched any
of my woman i would stand up against 10
men by myself and risk my life to
protect her i believe that women are
beautiful creatures i just don't think
that they're as emotionally calm as men
in stressful situations i don't think
they can fight like a man can and for
the same reason i would never drop my
children in an all-male nursery i think
that's strange and weird i would only
drop them in an all-female nursery women
do certain things and men do certain
things
now
i believe everything i said
i believe in protecting women i believe
in champion women i believe in making
sure that women are provided for
however
that video was made when i was far less
famous
in light of the things i just said to
you earlier in this video i understand
that now
as my fame grows even though to me my
message is very clear a man has certain
roles in society a woman has certain
roles in society and when we work as a
team when we love each other society is
better as a whole i think that's why
they don't want you having that people
who are on welfare if they get married
they lose part of their benefits so they
encourage people who are on welfare to
not be married but if they have more
children they get more more and more
benefits so you could just keep having
children at a wedlock then now they're
not raised in a two-parent household
which has been proven over and over and
over again to be a better situation for
children and it does it keeps people
trapped in the system and it keeps them
from generationally creating better
better and better situations for their
families absolutely right they know that
i've said it before i'll say it again go
look for research that shows the benefit
how wonderful the welfare system has
made people's lives it hasn't and they
know how to change they know how to
change it they know what it was supposed
to be a leg up and it should have been a
leg up and it can't i do believe in
giving people uh you know a push in the
right direction but they've created it
and set it up in such a way to keep
people trapped and keep them down and
keep them uneducated and in broken
families and they because we're easier
to control when we're broken and living
in drama if you give a man a fish you
feed him for a day if you teach a man to
fish you feed him for a lifetime and so
but they don't want to teach the men to
fish no they want to control the fish
and the fish being literally everything
in a person's life so you just keep
giving the guy fish and keep him in the
dark so he never learns and that's what
they're doing and if we change as a
society to teaching a man to fish what a
beautiful world we could live in if
everybody was productive in their heads
and they had self-worth and self-esteem
yeah they couldn't they wouldn't they
wouldn't let it happen because people
wouldn't have control oh boy this is a
weird time in life a few years ago
i don't think that they're controversial
most of the people i meet in the world
don't think they're controversial the
women i hang around with don't think
they're controversial nobody on the
street i've ever met thinks they're
controversial everybody agrees with me
however the way i'm saying it the way
i'm getting the message across because
i'm trying to be as energetic as
possible i understand that a small tiny
percentage of people might misunderstand
me and that didn't matter when i didn't
have any views i didn't have any
followers but now i'm the most famous
man in the world i have to be a lot more
careful with how i say it but what's
really worrying is this
that clip i would like to think even my
biggest haters can agree is a clip that
is positive about women as a whole
perhaps you may not like my tonality or
the way i structured certain sentences
but as a whole i'm saying positive
things about women
at one point during that speech i said
women do certain things and men do
certain things
that clip has been taken that cut of my
language men do certain things women do
certain things
somebody i have no idea who has made a
tick tock where it says men do certain
things and it shows videos of me driving
around in cars spending money
and women do certain things and it shows
women cleaning women do certain things
and men do certain things
somebody off their own back somebody
else has made that video i didn't tell
them to i don't know who they are i
don't know what their account is it's
just viral on the internet somewhere
and now i look like i'm saying women
should only clean and men should only
run around with cars and women and money
i didn't say that
i didn't say that at all i said that
women should be protected and provided
for but because a small clip was taken
out of context and used against me and
weaponized now i look like i've said
things i did not say and no matter how
positive my message about women if the
intention is to try and make me look bad
even with a clip like that they found a
way to make me look bad
how crazy still where the hell does
youtube get off even even if that was
his intention even if he was like
[ __ ] get in the kitchen you know what
who is youtube to take that down
[Music]